the picture is if you have not one but
two projectiles okay
so they're firing from opposite
direction toward each other so they are
on the same plane here and they're
firing two projectiles and it's all
about a collision that may or may not
happen okay what would it require for
their particles to quiet and if they do
can we find out some stuff about okay so
because there's so much to this question
what you'll find is sometimes a question
will do this they'll say look just
assume don't worry don't come from X
double dot big zero and y double dot be
negative G negative gravity don't worry
about starting from acceleration and
integrating all the way that's routine
it's the same pretty much every single
time and so this is kind of their way of
saying look we get it we know you can do
that okay at the end after your four
integrations are sorting out your four
clusters you'll land here okay so they
say assume that these are your
displacement equations for horizontal
and vertical and here is where the
question begins you can pull up 13 if
you like so you can look ahead but the
first part says if it's known that the
particles do actually collide if they do
fly through the air in some particular
arrangement and somewhere in the middle
here they actually hit each other and
prove this result / that there's this
relationship between the firing angles
and the firing velocities okay yes
um that's a really good question to us
in fact it's the first question of going
to answer because let's think about this
excuse me this is all talking in general
terms this is what happens if you
integrate something with any given
velocity and angle okay but we know all
the things we've been through here so
far we're going from left to right move
from left to right but the first
challenge is I have one of my client
girls that is not going from left to
right okay so in order to start this
proof the first thing I need is I want
expressions not just for like general
displacement but for the displacement of
these guys okay so here's what I'm gonna
do I think they named the particles like
p1 and p2 okay so for the first one
which is is this one coming over here
we'll call this p1 for the first one
everything is nice and ordinary you
start from the origin you go in from
left to right off across so therefore
you pretty much gonna quote all of these
things except you've got a particular
velocity and a particular angle okay so
I'm just going to go ahead and quote
those for p1 I'm going to quote the
horizontal displacement now a better
distinguish between those I'm gonna have
a lot of equations for air so we're
gonna say XY is V 1 T cos theta 1 so
this is V T cos theta for the particular
angle and the particular velocity of the
initial fire rate and in the same way
what I want is going to be all the same
except for this I'm gonna have V one
side that's all nice that's my first
particle okay my second particle goes
little more complicated
for instance that X 2 right that where
is where is this second particle
beginning ok immediately you can see two
things right number one it doesn't start
at the origin right so even though it's
kind of nice that they gave us these
equations because you skipped over the
fact that we just stopped resellers
should they go to velocity then get your
displacement
we don't know how to adjust this
directly in order to get something for
here it's starting somewhere else and
it's also going somewhere else right so
how could I care for these things yeah
their head okay that's right so the
first you will do is let's think about
time zero at time zero where is the
second particle and the interest it's at
B okay now I'm talking about like
quantities not positions so therefore
I'm going to name this distance heat
which I don't know I'll call that a B
right that's the name of this distance
right so at time zero I have to begin
there where does that make sense so this
is this would come out of being
integrated and saying at time zero x
equals that so that would be the cost of
integration but does that make sense if
I'd gone through it got all my six
equations from scratch in the same way
though as time progresses what happens
to the horizontal position of particle
two it's getting smaller isn't it's
going in this direction so this total
length wherever a picture is it's
getting smaller small and small as one
to make it smaller
I clearly must subtract right but what
I'm subtracting is the distance that
I've traveled which is this generally
speaking okay
so therefore it's going to be the two
time sign of theater sorry cos ya
thinking horizontally go pointing with
the first one for me okay wonderful
so you can see be careful I've had to
account for the fact that I've got a
different starting position and I'm
going in a different direction
now there we go - why - thankfully
because I'm still firing from the ground
I'm still firing up in some direction
actually the white shoe is going to be
exactly the same as this but of course
for twos instead of one right so I'm
still gonna have the influence of
gravity which is still the same and I'm
still gonna have plus because it's still
going up right so this is going to be v2
and now I'm gonna use side it's a bit
quite correctly okay right so now I've
set up my equations for displacement in
order for the particles to collide
remember I said to you the equations are
not that hard it's how you use the
equations right if the particles collide
what does that mean about the
relationships of these two equations
okay so the first thing you'll notice is
when you have a look at this this
they've handily given you the result is
really quite the truth right where does
this appear in our equations these are
all in the Y equations right so what
they're doing is they're saying hey you
know these things they should be the
same right if there is some kind of
collision then at a particular time why
I wanted Y to they better be the same
now I'll point out you're colliding
right so it's not just why I want to
want to that'd have to be the same right
yeah x1 x2 they also have to be at the
same time at the same place at the same
time okay so here's what I'm going to
say if the particles if the particles
collide
then this sometime like I need a need a
name for this because I don't know all
of this is like algebra I don't know any
of these values right so I'm gonna say
at some time let's call it capital T
this should be a collision X 1 at X 2
should be the same why would a
white-shoe should be the same okay so
I'm gonna say them one at a time
x1 equals x2 horizontally up in the same
spot so let me write this out I'm gonna
get V 1 T cos theta 1 equals that's X 1
equals a big takeaway so here context -
ok so this must be true ok but I know
two things number 1 this is probably not
going to get me the result I'm after
secondly I don't know what a B is right
you notice that so there's not much I
can do to simplify this guy it's kind of
stuck but then I say as well as that
simultaneously my Y values also have to
do the same right so I'm gonna say why
one should also be equal to Y 2 right
and this is gonna be helpful for us to
get our result you can see why right
let's um you see why let's court the
results for y1 and
and you can see even as I write it
what's going to happen yeah what's going
to take place a whole water kids lead
yeah you're going to add half GT squared
to both sides as soon as you do that
you're going to what are you doing
yes whoops I did something naughty by
the way which is that this is actually a
particular time there's a particular
time so this really should be that time
whenever it is and that time whatever it
is as well as all of these I am going to
add half GT squared to both sides after
that I'm going to divide through by
whatever this time happens to be which
by the way as Jitsu I'm sure will point
out I can't do because because T can't
possibly be zero okay and then once
you've done that I will actually put our
line of working angles because it is a
show yes sorry you mean like that thank
you
and having divided through by mind on
zero now you here is the result that I
was required to show happy times now
maybe you've already gone down and how
to make a question thirteen and you can
see they have you proven this result
they then thankfully start to give us
some numbers they give us a whole bunch
and actually concrete values that we can
put into this and then they process some
questions